so I like Batman Forever this bit
terrible right so that's pretty
attention-seeking just a massive jet
flying through the middle of Gotham I
wonder I wonder where that look on that
rooftop there just drop something up
there
Oh what what's going on here there seems
to be a man changing oh yeah definitely
waist guy is it guys mask off I think
this is what always annoyed me about
this sequences a bat man standing in
broth will not broad daylight but you
know he's just had a jet draw attention
of this rooftop and then he's walking
around with his mask off strutting about
for the camera like some cosplay I who's
it's his first comic-con you know what I
mean he's walking around like hey Ichigo
on every trailer you know that because
every every trailer a comic-con is you
see unwatchable because they're just
like so we're announcing that Wonder
Woman is a woman he's exactly where you
just tried to fly to he's kept it cuz I
played this game before probably
shouldn't be clearly talking to the
commissioner's daughter on a comm
channel in front of a policeman over
there like a [ __ ] idiot I did always
kind of like this bit where he throws up
in scans the city even though the lad
could have went there before when I was
doing the training
he turned them Romney turn he knew
better than added even though of
completely the game about 75 times
because I've got no life
so yeah it's based on access chemicals I
like this sort of them I wouldn't there
if Suicide Squad stole from this because
Captain Boomerang does a bit like this
where he throws the Boomer I get it
spins around with that with a camera on
it yeah so it's good to see that this
game influenced something great
oscar-winning Suicide Squad yeah one
enough scale at film so very very good
film sure I will show you love it as
well I love how the lads got
remote-control tank but it's still it's
still jumping in it to fight people it
was very dangerous German and every -
like [ __ ] it you think I live this long
by doing smart [ __ ] no I stand in front
of helicopters and let them would have
targets on me anyway [ __ ] these lads
and so DC you've recently announced that
Batman is am a human which is a bit you
know it kind of goes against the law it
kind of goes against the main thing that
everyone likes Batman for which is that
he has no powers so they've just decided
all of us and yeah Batman actually is a
superhero and which a bit crack but
thinking about it what like if you can
answer this I'd appreciate it what
actually is his superheroes because
their superpowers because the guy conned
run fast
he doesn't have super strength he can't
like fly so is his metahuman power just
that he's Batman just a little just not
a thing the thing on there anyway guys I
know you love
in about DC all day like I do because
you're a loser and you will you are a
loser a few bloody watching this that's
all I can say
[Music]
morning ladies hahahahaha I just killed
you they might not be alive they're a
skeleton crew if he kept my drift
just a little bit of Gotham humor for
you there I never really understood and
this bit because Batman has absolutely
no idea who's in this so I don't know
why he walks - he walks to the end of
the bridge to stare down the helicopter
the lad seems to be a lot smarter than
that but yeah for some reason he just he
doesn't know that he doesn't know the
guy's not gonna kill him yeah it's just
oh yeah I just walk in front of my
enemies the guy seems to look more
tactical than that it seems they're very
stupid so was it was he just gonna stand
and let their latch on them you know it
doesn't doesn't really make sense I
never liked that bit in the game it
seemed a bit too action movie it it's
not the only bit I didn't like in the
game in fact I hate at every [ __ ]
tank section that that's coming up you
know I hate it as well
when Deathstroke greatest hanhan combat
fight yet in the DC Universe often
regarded as a better hand-to-hand combat
fighter damn Batman anyway they have a
big boss battle with him build up to it
build up to it
it's a [ __ ] tank fight always in the
[ __ ] tanks another thing I never got
about this game was I know I'm
nitpicking I do really like really
really like the game and it's one of my
favourite games of all time where did
they get all the money from for this
I've got absolutely no idea scarecrow
never had this much money Jason Todd was
dead for about 20s spoiler alert so
there's no way the lad would have all of
this money nothing about a higher five
thousand people by seventeen million
times never-ending stream at tanks and
all this [ __ ] which was in the boys
Kenneth or might be right shall go
because in the under the hood graphic
novel don't know but Jason tall was
actually brought back by Rachel ghoul
and he was sort of brain dead for a bit
but then Superman I think it was did
something quite remember what he did and
he so that's that's a good at trivia
fair he did something and it caused a
sonic boom which allowed Jason Todd to
come back to life I saw something but
Jason Todd I was alive inside his grave
I think it was and he beat his way out
but he was severely brain-damaged from
the Joker
so the latter little lad who was a
mental and then I think they dropped him
in the Lazarus Pit he came back so bit
of trivia for you there and story was
written by Judd Winick who also wrote
the animated version of it animated
version is much much better than their
graphic novel it's so much better than
it that I actually I bought the graphic
novel one thing you know you know
graphic novel visions normally better
than an animated movie read it and when
right what the hell is this and just
list it listed on eBay straight away
often when I'm angry with things I just
list them on eBay
and under the hood was one of those ones
that I just
and apparently Judd Winick the writer
actually wrote the animated version of
it because he just thought up words yeah
this is in there
this isn't originally as good as I
thought it was gonna be that sounds like
something to say when they don't really
know any technical terms like if you
watch The Bourne Supremacy or something
the latest one anyway anyway some reason
they say like hey that SQL is
downloading to the database on the new
ruder modem thing and he just like yeah
may I work in computers you've got no
[ __ ] idea what you're talking about
whoever wrote that clearly just went
through my CV two years ago where I just
wanted a job in the internet stuff so
just watch this google loads of
buzzwords and just wrote any [ __ ] on
them and so thanks very much for
checking out my CV by the way writers of
The Bourne Identity it's just a shame
that you couldn't write your home and
good film in the last one you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] I like
how the guy kind of breaks them down so
it's sort of teasing you who who is you
know I mean like you know who he's gotta
know Batman well to be able to say oh I
know all the places just to touch him I
used to touch him in those special
places that those were the sensitive
places so the guy clearly knows him well
on an intimate level some would say mmm
ace chemicals very famous pop of the
Batman law depending on what origins
story of the Joker you believe then this
is the place that caused his accident
where that bleach his skin look very
cool they're just stepping our when to
hitting the switch that's why you should
never make X you jump and
activate button but anyway I digress if
you've seen Batman in 1989 and let's
face it you probably have because you're
watching an Arkham Knight playthrough
like a bloody idiot probably on a Friday
night what the hell is wrong with you
get a life then it was called axis
chemicals and that which is a bit
strange I never quite got why they they
had a different name for both of them
but you know the origin story in em of
the Joker is very much the same as the
one in the Killing Joke except for in
The Killing Joke it kind of revolves
around the Red Hood and so basically in
The Killing Joke there's a guy called
where I don't always call anyway he's a
stand-up comedian he's wife's pregnant
he wants a bit of money you know he
wants a bit of money to provide for his
family can't pay the rent stand-up
comedy's not not paying much he's not
very funny he reminds me a bit of myself
so he basically joins this criminal
fraternity to do a robbery on ACE
chemicals which is where he's to work as
he knows the ins and outs of it they
look the criminals are of course very
interested in having his insight in his
knowledge so the higher the guide the
higher the lab anyway during one of the
meetings he finds out the his wife as
being she's just died there was a
toaster malfunction or something like
that something ridiculous and which was
it was the point of it and she's dead so
the criminals are look yeah you Buda cat
you better still go through with a job
you know think about how lovely of a
funeral your wife's gonna have because
you're gonna be a bloody rich so the guy
goes through with it and he regrets it
when he's you know he's mines obviously
on other things when he goes to gots to
do the job anyway they didn't realize
they've got bloody security in there and
and you know the the two mobsters at
Eastwood doing the job worth get shot I
should have really scanned for them you
know what I'm not I know in the game you
meant actually scan for these dead
workers before you go and see them and
I'm not gonna bother cause I'm about it
anyway Batman shows up on the scene and
he sees the lad any luck yet you're
coming with me the guy jack will call
them he stumbles into over a railing and
lands he just he just lands in the pool
of slime and toxin the guy gets brush
out the pipe the other the other side
any emerges as the Joker and so quite a
big significant location in the Batman
mythology if you you one of those people
like me who thinks the Joker's Batman's
best villain then this is pretty much
theis massively and his origin story so
really good and they also revisit
in 0ya which is sort of the new 52
retelling of the batman origin story and
that's that's like it's it's sort of a
similar story it's a bit more
action-packed but yeah really really
good definitely recommend checking out
the Killing Joke which is one of the
best Batman stories ever and zero yes
also one of the best as well so yeah
make sure you get them on your reading
list what they do another like [ __ ]
him up the arse or something there so
one in the best bits of Batman V
Superman was how much they got like the
the combat scene right when Batman
breaks in to save Martha Martha just
that fight scene especially in the
extended edition way it's just
absolutely like brutalizing people and
it's one of the best scenes in a comic
book film ever I think I mean sometimes
I just load that up on what on YouTube
just to watch it it's so well
choreographed and it just completely
catches Batman would fight I remember
watching the raid for the first time and
there's a scene in that where the main
character I don't know the lads name I
don't want to say anything that could be
in case I'm wrong and I sound like a
racist you know I'm not Pro Donald Trump
yeah he just has like such a good fight
in that and I was like oh if they ever
made a Batman movie with that scene and
a guy who fights like that it would be
like bang on so when the Zack Snyder one
dropped and I seen that trailer the
first trailer where they pretty much
show the warehouse fight I actually went
into my room and like
cried for a bit because I was just like
oh my god they completely nailed the
fight and just the fighting from from
top to bottom and I just nailed all the
fight in there cuz I got like in a e82
combo clash there so shout out to me and
they'll get more than Schneider nailed
there and say whatever you want about
Zack Snyder that scene alone it's like
amazing like I really hope the Justice
League has a scene like that because
it's so so good and you can literally
like if someone ever says you know why
do you like Batman just show them that
scene sometimes I wonder if Alfred just
said that because he's like yeah I just
kill this lie just kill him you know
what the best way to war Batman's plan
in this game would be would just put
people in the tank crazy cuz he was like
only shooting this now cuz he thinks
there's no one in it see Alfred should
have just lighting the lad if he had to
kill them and the whole game would have
been over
everyone understood him it would there
wouldn't have been mad there'd be me
yeah who's gonna who's gonna murder
everyone in this city yeah you know I
mean I think people like can be quite
understanding of murder if the if it's
like the best option like a lot of
people kick off about Superman
killing General Zod in Man of Steel I
seem to be the only one who was like nah
it's fine yeah yeah he had to do it I
mean there's no prison on earth that can
hold Zod they didn't know about
kryptonite back then yeah he has to kill
him if anything he should be should have
killed them already shouldn't be letting
the lad walk around and Zod Bailey was
like look we're gonna fight to the death
I'm not I'm not messing about here soon
I will knock here out
I think that was the line from the
script and so he had no choice if
Batman's killed in the comics before and
you know even Batman Begins he left
Rachele Ghul died in that train I don't
care about the whole like I'm not gonna
save you I don't have to save you like
yeah you are killing them you that's
definitely murder you know that's not
like a good thing that's like seeing
someone in the house fire you could have
helped them out instead you don't that
doesn't not make you like a murderer you
let that guy die so Batman's you has
he's killed a couple of times I mean
Batman's origin in the thirties he
murdered people left right and center
and it has slowly been brought to you
know he doesn't kill well I think would
have been great in Batman V Superman is
if Batman actually didn't kill in that
movie like they're one of the big
criticisms of Batman V Superman other
than the terrible script and Lex Luthor
being absolutely terrible and you just
want to kick its head in is that Batman
kills in it and it would have been so
much better with driving or style there
would have been so much better if Batman
like I hadn't have killed people but it
was so like scared of Superman that he
was like oh this is gonna be this is
gonna be the first like person I ever
kill and but it's it's the only way and
then you know when he's holding that
spear over his head and he's about to
stab him just before he says Martha a
terrible terrible he's like oh this is
gonna be my first kill you know it would
make it so much more dramatic but
instead they just have a Batman gunning
people down left right and center which
yeah no not a good thing but you know
I'd forgive him for killing the arkham
knight the lad was a [ __ ]
you